this is such an unlikely subject you
would think so how did you come up with
this idea and think that it would have
the dramatic content to sustain a
feature or a documentary so I was a
science fair kid for two years in a row
and I competed in the fair that you just
saw two years that it totally changed my
life and you know validates why you're
in movies now exactly I was a sociology
so I've always been interested in people
but you know I it taught me at a young
age that my ideas were important and it
during the dark years of high school
validated my passions and my ideas and
all that and then when I became an adult
I realized how important it was to me
and I also just remembered this world so
fondly and I would always tell stories
to my friends about you know the science
fair dance and all these other dorky
things that I remember and you know we
were were investigative journalists so
we were working on a very dark story
about Fenton altogether Darrin and I and
I told him about this world and I said
I've always kind of wanted to do a
documentary on it and he said let's do
it and yeah two years two years later
here we are
and so Darrin how did you two sync with
this did you have to be convinced that
this was a good movie a good idea I mean
I thought it had a lot of potential once
Christina told me about it just because
the story she would tell me weren't so
much about the science and the you know
that she saw the fair but it was these
amazing scenes that you would describe
like the science fair dance and the
characters that she met so I was already
really primed to you know to do the
documentary but then we went on a
scouting trip in 2016 to CISF and once I
went in there I was totally convinced
that this would be an epic subject for a
documentary was Jeffrey in from the
beginning on the scouting expedition did
they come to you afterwards yeah they
know I was not I mean I knew these guys
were doing it but I was working on other
stuff and you know Darren and I had
worked together for like a decade or so
so but I didn't get Christina's whole
pitch so when Darren had called me he
was like I think we're gonna need you to
help put this thing together and I was
like which thing he's like the science
fair thing that's like hmm
Wow let's see how that goes it was not
you know the it's to me that's the whole
thing it's like it's not a world that
seems full of drama or humor or anything
so you know I think as soon as I started
looking at the footage of the kids I was
sold but Darren's not much of a Salesman
he didn't know I don't undersell things
it spoke for itself so Robbie how did
they approach you by the way Robbie is
wearing one of his shirt so if you can't
see so there's Windows Windows 95 yeah
Oh classic so so Christina and Darren
met me in 2016 at the ICF there's one
shot of me in the movie where I have
really short hair and that is that is
when they met and you were like a foot
and a half shorter yeah yeah that too
um but it was kind of just random chance
how they met me and then after that they
they decided to keep me for whatever
reason and and I was in the dock and did
you think that this was going to be a
movie about science or how did they
present it to you I think they told me I
was a movie about science fair but I
mean I never thought that it would be
you know as big as as it's been um I
think over time you know what when we
would you know get further into filming
I started to realize that you know maybe
this is like actually like a legit like
legit thing but um at first it was just
like you know sure why not like but uh
but it was it was a really fun thing to
be a part of and I really did love it
for Darren and Christina at at what
point did you enter this process because
there's some archival footage and then
there's all the stuff that you shot and
you wanted obviously to tell the story
start to finish so where did you enter
it and how did you have to backfill
because while it's an easy movie to
watch it had to be a pretty difficult
one to shoot and edit yeah it was kind
of a puzzle to figure out how we got
coverage of all these different regional
affairs when you don't know who's going
to qualify so you know we started like
we started at scouting in 2016 and from
there we kind of placed some bets
so cash via for example and Robbie we
met at the 2016 qualifying fairs so they
were the horses you were backing here
right yeah
yeah well then you know then we
basically look for the powerhouse
schools they were the easy ones identify
the perennial powerhouses like Jericho
high school or dr. McCulloh Works DuPont
manual also just every year just turns
out these kids who do really well the
science fair so we knew we that was a
good starting point to find kids the the
underdog stories are a little more
difficult but we knew we wanted the team
from Brazil because from our scouting
trip Brazil is just the loudest and the
proudest allegation they're they're a
lot of fun but we also had found out
Brazil has their their qualifying fair
very early and so we knew who had
qualified for ICF and we just went
through the list while Christina went
through the list and called every single
person and we landed on milena and
Gabrielle because they were doing the
Zika research and obviously that was you
know a topic that pretty much everybody
knew about by this point and they were
just you know even though they didn't
speak English a lot of the kids did
speak English we just felt that they lit
up the screen in other ways Jeffrey how
hard was it to put together all this
material with the time sequencing I mean
this was as we saw in the time stamps
sometimes it was a matter of minutes
when the judges were command coming in
when the doors were being closed the
writing in the editing must have just
been a monster to think of that yeah
they're definitely like parts of it were
easier you know once you've got to yeah
I mean they're parts of the film were
easy to put together
because you're sort of handcuffed to the
chronology of the contest but there are
other parts that were really difficult I
mean the order you know you really sort
of we really struggled to try and find
the right order for the to meet the kids
you know because you that section of the
movie needs to do a lot of things you
need to meet a lot of kids pretty
quickly you also have to set up the
stakes I mean it is you do fall in love
with the kids but we also need to set up
the stakes of this competition that it
is this life-changing thing especially
for certain kids so anyway so it's
trying to do you know a little history a
little this and that so it yeah you know
this is the ugliness of when the sausage
gets made what one of the subtext is
really how little these accomplishments
are regarded by the schools I mean
there's that awful scene with kospi and
nobody at her school knew who she was
she comes back after winning first prize
and doesn't even get acknowledged by the
school whereas the first win in two
seasons by the football team you would
have thought it was manna from heaven
yeah I mean that but it's not just South
Dakota we know this it's it's all over
the country where this is happening I do
think that coach MIT is a great icon and
a great model for what a supportive you
know mentor can look like he has no idea
about anything having to do with science
but yet he he agrees to help cash via
weight what you don't see in the movie
is he's also the head of the feminist
Club he's incredibly supportive mentor
so I think for for us he was kind of a
silver lining in this kind of sad story
that that this film can do anything to
reach people who are thinking Oh science
not interesting nerdy too hard oh yeah I
mean definitely definitely especially
since you know it isn't really like
there I mean I don't want to say like
there's not like a lot of like science
and the phone but it does it's not like
super like technical and I think that
you know it's it's more accessible and I
mean science fair successfully anybody
can do science fair um but but yeah I
really do think that that it will and
then it sends a strong message that like
you know science fair is like really a
really fun thing to do you know I think
can I jump in oh please yeah no I just
been one of the fun things at a few of
the screenings you know a lot of the
students were were there and it is
amazing to see the kids at the
screenings find them afterwards and and
and you know little girls weeping when
they're meeting ievo and you know it's
just like it's have they been cutting
off pieces of your hair to my knowledge
we had her premiere there is literally a
line of kids like following Robbie
around like like puppies wow this is a
good sign and so Geoffrey when you were
writing and obviously you know kind of
shaping this film did you sense that
this was the balance you were navigating
here with these kids with the science
and with their stories I mean I
obviously this is you know it's about
the kids you know and then we the
critics the one thing that sort of gets
when when we read a review is is that
the you know there's not enough science
in the movie wait wait that was a
filmstrip in eighth grade that's a very
different thing right what's the the
science was in a filmstrip in eighth
grade it's just this is not a movie
intended to teach science I thank you
yes no if it's it's a celebration of
these kids and and and they're sort of
you know curiosity in there and they're
you know I just their their whole effort
to sort of push you know where science
is going but it but yeah it's it's about
the kids it's it's like a human story
and and it is as Sciences is difficult
to celebrate in in a way that you know
sports isn't you know it's it's more
watchable more accessible and so I think
that ultimately is like the great
success of this is to make a science
fair competition super watchable and and
you're rooting for these kids to win the
science fair I mean it's like a very
simple thing but it's also like why it
works I think congratulations it's
really charming and it carries a message
and a lot of substance and a lot of
heart so thank you all